(whistling music)
- I go off of looks.
- You give me like boujee looks.
I would put you in the front.
- I agree actually.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna shoot down like three spots.
- I disagree.
I personally believe you
probably make $1 billion.
(laughing)
- I agree.
I was gonna say the same thing.
He gives me maybe gamer.
- Yeah, I'm gonna put him in the middle.
- He's still mentally here for me.
- I feel like your shoes,
Raya are kind of expensive.
I can't tell if it's like a knockoff
but quality platforms are usually like
- Plus the all black
- [Hayley] $200 to $300.
- You give me like you have
like a million followers
on Instagram and you do like
model shoots every single day
like fashion shoots.
(camera clicking)
- So I want to put her in the middle.
- What's your name over there?
- Grace?
- I don't know.
You give me like the vibe that you have,
you make a lot of money like
selling cookies with your nice
or like sweaters on Etsy or something.
- Like sweet, very sweet.
- Yeah, very sweet artist vibes.
- And you have a fun TikTok.
So I think you are like over here.
Over here. Yeah.
- I like this.
- I kind of like it.
- I'm cool with this too.
- You think this makes sense?
- I'm gonna disagree.
I think Raya should be one more ahead.
- Okay.
- I would put Josh
like further
- in front of me maybe?
- Yeah, maybe between you two?
- Yeah, I agree.
- I would be good right here.
(all laughing)
- Josh?
- No, come on.
- Josh, where's your sweater from?
- H&M.
- H&M, okay.
- But, H&M's like a classic though.
Like, I know a lot of guys who wear
only H&M but they make good money.
- Well, like a lot of
girls wear FashionNova
but they're wearing like
a thousand dollars shoes.
- True.
- So.
- I don't hate this lineup.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm okay.
- You think this is the lineup?
- Okay.
- I make TikTok videos about
tech reviews and tech stuff.
- Oh, that's money.
- I run a couple businesses from it.
- What kind of tech businesses?
Like laptops and computers?
- Like type-on keyboards.
I make custom ones and I also now am
getting into clothes, so
I designed this hoodie.
- I feel like you're great with money.
So even if you maybe
technically didn't bring in
as much as some other
of us a couple years ago
you maybe have grown it more because
you're probably very smart.
I'm sure you're investing.
I feel like you absolutely need to go
higher up.
- I think so too.
- How many TikTok accounts do you have?
- Three that have done well.
- You should take my spot;
it's scary over here.
- I would put you like second or third.
- Yeah, I would put you second.
- Let's do second.
- Tech is a lot of money.
(Cha-Ching)
- Plus you have all those
other income streams
on top of it too.
- Yeah.
- So I teach people how
to be content creators
but I'm also a Twitch streamer.
- Do you sell a course?
- I was just about to ask.
- Ah, I don't sell a
course because I believe
in making education free for people.
So I don't like paywalling info.
- How do you make your
income without the ads?
- So I get $2.50 for every sub that I get.
That's one way that I make my money
and TikTok sponsorships mainly.
And I also have Instagram
and YouTube and stuff
but they're like really small.
- I mean those are two
pretty lucrative platforms.
But also you have a lot of morals
which makes me think you
don't make as much money
(sad trumpet playing)
you haven't sold your soul.
- Yeah, I mean with the
L.A. rent rising though.
(laughing)
- I still don't think you
should be last though.
- I don't feel like she should move
until we hear a couple more.
- Yeah, yeah. I would
keep myself down here.
- I was gonna be like, bring her here.
(laughing)
- So I do a few different things.
My big one is I am a sex
educator, so I host a podcast.
We just launched the third season.
So, I've been doing that since 2019.
And I do sex education content
on my Instagram as well as on my TikTok.
And then I also upload
all the podcasts episodes
to my YouTube channel.
- Ooh.
- With YouTube,
you got ad revenue.
- And she's been doing it
for three years.
- But my one caveat is sex education,
which in terms of making
money through sponsorships
- It's harder.
- Not many companies would
wanna unfortunately work
with a sex educator,
even though I think it's a cool thing.
- And it's harder to get ad
revenue because I'm constantly
working through bans
- Shadow bans.
- and things like that.
- How are you making most
of your money though?
- Through all of those
as well as OnlyFans.
- Ooh, but OnlyFans makes money.
- Yeah, you can bank.
- OnlyFans has such an uncapped potential;
I would put you up here.
- Third.
- Top three for sure.
- Okay.
- All right, so I make
content just around money
and I try and teach Gen Z
good money habits with
short little funny videos.
- Finance makes so much
money because not only do
they push it but you also
get so many sponsorships,
especially from YouTube.
Are you on YouTube or are
you on primarily TikTok?
- It goes like in this order:
TikTok, Instagram, YouTube stuff.
- I feel like those
videos also, especially
in the way you do them with
comedy are super shareable.
Like those are the kind of
TikToks that end up on reels,
they end up on Facebook.
- I would put you up because
- Definitely.
- finance is such a lucrative niche.
- I'm okay with that.
(laughing)
- He is like, yeah!
- Okay, I am a TikToker.
- I knew it.
(laughing)
I knew; I could tell.
- I do like mostly fashion
stuff like secondhand fashion
vintage stuff and lifestyle.
- What do you sell?
- I don't really anymore.
I started my TikTok promoting
my online vintage shop
and that's how I became a TikToker
and now I just do fashion stuff.
- Do you do it full-time?
- Yeah.
- So your revenue comes
from sponsorships?
- Yeah, it's like all social media now.
- I don't know, fashion
makes no money unless
you're a thin white woman.
(crickets chirping)
(Hayley laughing)
So, she's a thin white woman, so!
Being plus size in the
social media industry
is definitely been hard.
There's visibly fat plus size
people and then there's people
with the quintessential perfect curves.
Like almost, unfortunately,
how plus size are you?
- If you do lifestyle but
you're a small creator,
you get nothing.
Like they literally only gifting campaigns
and then like even then they gaslight you
into feeling like you
should be grateful for it.
- Yeah absolutely.
- But given,
I'm guessing you sound like you're
a very large creator and then I feel
like I've seen your
video on my For You page.
I would maybe put you first.
(cymbal clanging)
- Oh, don't do that.
I'm also, this is my first
year doing this (beep).
- Yeah, you don't
know anyone's sizes.
- I'd say right here.
- I don't think I make more than you.
- We still have time to switch.
- [Grace] That's true.
- Okay, so I am a plus sized supermodel
so everything I do is pretty
much lifestyle around that
and it's been my full-time
job for about four years now.
I have my own cannabis and
sexual wellness podcast
so I do that separately.
I also have my own consultation
and coaching business
where I teach aspiring
plus size models.
So. I have an online
course that's a masterclass
that I do quarterly.
And then I also have a blog separately
that I post on one to
at least once a week.
And the ad marketing is just starting
on my blog so it's not too far in there.
But I'm very familiar with
ad marketing and revenue.
I have a a lot.
- I would put you first.
- Absolutely.
- Like, you have so many
streams of income.
- So many streams of income.
- You just seem very, very knowledgeable.
- And what about you Kazumi?
- I do OnlyFans, I also do
YouTube; I also do Instagram.
My main stream of income though is TikTok,
not specifically from ad revenue,
but I make like seven to 10 TikToks
and I just like pump out as
many reels of me as I can.
- A day?
- Yes.
- Wow!
- With different captions
and I just lead it back to my OnlyFans.
But I do, I make a lot of memes.
That's like my kind of like niche.
I make porn in memes.
- Do you have a billboard in Wejo?
- (laughing) Yeah, I do.
I do have a billboard in Wejo.
- I saw that.
- Yeah.
- Do you take sponsorships?
- No, I'm a sex worker so they don't,
sponsors don't want me or my
face to represent their brand.
- The only reason I get away
with that is because I also
am a sex educator.
So, but I completely understand.
The second they hear
that you have any sort of
like OnlyFans or sex work.
- Yeah and I've gotten
deleted like seven times.
- Yes.
- Where do you rank; what's
your percentage on OnlyFans?
- I'm 0.01%.
- Okay. Number one.
Number one.
- Whoa!
- Number one.
- Y'all can switch.
- Absolutely.
- How many guys you been with?
- I used to do (beep) parties
and I would get (beep)
for like 50 dudes a night.
- Okay, so you're on No Jumper.
- Yeah.
- That's the kind of
video that goes viral.
I mean there's
- Yeah.
- no doubt about that.
That video has millions of views.
- So my photo is a photo of me in Vogue.
(gasping)
So I'm--
- It's a beautiful photo.
My butts in Vogue.
- Does Vogue pay a lot?
- It's almost kind of like
being a Playboy centerfold
in a sense of like it's an honor.
- Okay.
- Congrats on your new baby.
- [Computer] Insert cash
or select payment type.
Use pin pad to complete transaction.
- I'm sorry, what?
- The average cost of
childbirth and pregnancy here
in the US is $6,940 with health insurance
or $13,000 without,
and it can vary wildly.
- I changed my mind.
What's your return policy like?
(laughing)
- This is my dad
and this is his at-home work setup.
He hates it.
So today I'm gonna try to fix it.
I'm gonna first add a
custom keyboard I built
for him and a mouse.
And then we're gonna go ahead and give him
the Fopo triple monitor laptop adapter.
This is gonna turn his single
laptop screen
(crowd oohs)
into a triple monitor adapter.
- I do a lot of Get Ready with Me's.
I gotta take an Instagram picture.
And I wanna stay in this sweater.
So this is where we're at.
I kind of think that these bell bottoms
- [Woman] Love those pants.
- would be cool with this
and it kind of matches and it would edge
up the sweater a little bit and make it
a little more me.
Well, here they are.
As you can see
- [Woman] That's so cute.
- I need to be a little bit taller
for these and I think it'll be
a crime not to to wear these.
- (gasping) I love the fit.
- Yeah.
- That's pretty much what I do.
- Oh my God, that's so cute.
- Thanks.
- Our noses smushed up against
our kissing partner's face
is actually opening up our nostrils
and making their pheromones
more obvious to us.
And whether you realize it or not,
your body will actually react
to that person's pheromones
and can make you more attracted to them
if your body thinks they're
a good biological match.
- I would kiss you.
- That's woke.
- Best websites for for Twitch streamers.
TwitchTracker is a website
that tracks your stream data.
It'll show you the max
viewers, follower, gains
in the amount of hours
you stream per stream.
They also have a very nice
graph showing your average
viewer account and the
amount you streamed.
And cool stats like average
viewer account per date.
- I'm subscribing.
- Yeah, that's similar
to the type of content that I do.
- That's so good to know.
- I feel like I should
go down in the tech men.
- The tech men should
definitely go up.
- I feel like I want
to put, I think your name is Teddy, right?
- Yes.
- You second,
because I saw that ad.
Tech pays well that ad
was really well edited.
I'm pretty sure companies
will see that and be like,
I wanna go and sponsor him again.
Well I'll put you second.
- I put you second.
- Yeah.
- Gee. I'll take it.
- I'm okay where I'm at.
(whistle)
(crowd cheering)
- You guys feel like numbers,
like the follower count matters?
- No. Oh hell no.
- Absolutely not.
One thing I'd like to say is like quality,
depending what industry you're in.
Because I have a friend who has
quadruple the following I do
and 10 times the engagement
and I make three times as much
as she does because of the quality
and I sell usage rights so
people can use it as ads.
- I feel that.
- Yeah!
- I think you gotta move up.
- I would put you second.
- How many hours do you guys work?
I work every day.
- A lot.
- Yeah, like this week I
worked like four 18 hour days.
At minimum, there's no day
where I'm working less.
Like almost every single
day where I'm working
less than five hours, at least.
- I'm not trying to diminish
what they were saying.
Like it is hard work.
And like when she was
talking about like work
doesn't end, but it does.
You can go get (beep) a smoothie and sit
in your bed and scroll emails.
It's not the same as being
expected to be somewhere
and be a slave all day
and be off your phone.
Like you're not a person
when you're at work
but you're a person when
you're doing this job.
- It's hard when you do a job like this
because at first I was like,
oh I don't actually work
that many hours but then
the second I wake up
I'm checking and I'm deciding
what I'm gonna do that day.
- Yeah.
- And that's actually
all the day everyday.
(all agreeing)
- It's how you decipher what's work
and what's not.
- Yeah so it's hard
when you're not doing it.
Like I'm maybe not working
four hours straight
because I'll stop and I have the privilege
of being able to grab
lunch with friends or shop
in the middle of the day
or like do whatever I do.
But that doesn't mean I'm not constantly
you know, working in some capacity,
so it's hard--
- And weekend don't exist.
- Right, exactly. Yeah, yeah.
There's really no days off.
- How was your come up?
Because I started with gaming content
and then I transitioned into education.
- I did too.
- Like when, oh my God, love gaming.
But especially as like a
female gamer who was trying
to do content, I got memed on so much.
Everyone's like, "Oh my
God you're such an e-girl."
"Like yeah, ABG, big e-girl aesthetic."
"Haha. You suck at the game anyways."
- And now it's in!
- Dude!
I know and now it's cool, right?
- What year were you doing that?
- I was doing it in like 2018, 2019.
- I was doing it in 2011.
- Oh.
- To be a female YouTuber
in a male dominated space
in 2011 was traumatizing.
- [Hayley] Brutal.
- I have a question for you, Josh.
Do you feel like you have to work harder
or fight for what you're
worth as a black man?
- I don't know if I necessarily
have to fight harder
but it is a little bit harder to stand out
and like get people to take you seriously.
It's actually one of the
reasons that I've signed
with a management agency
that only represents
black creators.
- Oh okay.
- I love that.
- Yeah, so it just feels
like a small family.
- Absolutely.
- And you know, I know
that they're out there
fighting to do like what's best for me.
- They're on your team.
- They've been so helpful
because I've run into
other black creators that
have my similar following
and a similar niche.
I mean they're earning way
less and there's so much
more money out there that
they're just not getting mostly
because they don't know
exactly what they're worth.
- I don't know, this
looks like it makes sense.
- I feel like it doesn't.
I feel like I need to go down
one or two.
- I want to move down.
- I feel like with the YouTube ad sense,
maybe I would switch this?
- I think we should switch.
- Maybe?
- And Josh you have a manager, I don't.
- Okay, but I wanna say this though.
I have a modeling agency
and 80% of the work that
I get, I get myself.
- That's fair.
- It's more about him getting one.
I don't feel the need for
one cause I don't think
I'm getting as many maybe as he is.
- Interesting.
- That's just my take.
- You have
- multiple business.
- What's your
second biggest channel again?
- It's for my business and it has 75,000.
Now I have employees and I
don't really do anything.
- Oh you have employees?
- I really don't think I should be here.
I think he needs--
- You need to be second.
- to maybe move up.
- He has employees?
- I feel like I just wanna move myself
in between
- In between us.
That makes sense to me.
- Or like lower.
- How do we feel about this?
- This? Yeah.
This looks like our final answer.
- I think we're good with this.
- [Crew] Seventh spot
Teddy at 115k annually.
- What?
- That was a shocker.
- No way!
- [Crew] Sixth spot Hayley, 125k.
(money Cha-Ching)
- Six figure club.
(laughing)
- [Crew] Fifth spot, Kat at 175k.
(money Cha-Ching)
Fourth spot, Grace at 180k.
And the third spot, Josh, 275k.
- I knew you were up here.
- [Crew] And in the
second spot, Raya, 300k.
(money Cha-Ching)
And the first spot,
Kazumi at 3 million.
(exciting Cha-Ching)
- Damn!
- Oh my God.
- Sex workers.
(laughing)
- Yeah, let's go!
Big W for us.
- Retire tomorrow.
(laughing)
(upbeat drumming)
- People hate when you make a lot of money
in a non-traditional way
and they really hate when
you make it off sex work.
- Yeah.
- So I was very, very
nervous about the reaction.
- I am an anomaly and I
don't represent what all
sex workers make.
I make a lot of money.
But it is still something that
you should deeply consider
before getting into because
it is something that holds
a lot of social stigma
and does make life hard
if you don't like doing it.
- And I just want to say
that y'all have motivated me
because I feel like I
became like comfortable
with what I was doing and
like I haven't been pushing
myself recently but now I'm
like, y'all are doing so well
and I'm like--
- Well that's crazy.
You woke up and made a
whole website by yourself.
- Trust me, that would
take me like three months
- It wasn't great.
- On my blog to do.
- Yeah, when I was 19, I was homeless.
So, I am really proud of
you and whatever you've done
and the fact that you can employ people
and do so many cool things with your life.
- I think there's an idea
of what an influencer is
in people's heads and I think it's usually
like a air-headed person
who just takes selfies
or uses a selfie stick.
They don't understand, I
think maybe the nuance.
- Like I was kind of weird coming into it
because I grew up really poor
and like $180,000 is
like so much money to me.
I would be happy making
the amount of money
I make right now for the rest of my life.
And I feel like everyone
gets into it and they're like
I have to be a millionaire
and I have to like monetize
every category of my life.
And that's probably where it
becomes like an insane job.